how much do you connect the ideas of
communism or marxism or socialism
to
holland more to stalin's rule so how
naturally is he kind of alluded to does
it lead to genocide
that's also uh
i mean in some ways i've just addressed
that question by saying it doesn't
always lead to genocide
you know in the case again you know cuba
is not pretty
uh but it didn't have
there was no genocide in in cuba and
same thing in north vietnam
um you know even north korea is awful as
it is a terrible dictatorship right and
and people's rights are totally
destroyed right they have no freedom
whatsoever
you know is not as far as we know
genocidal
who knows whether it could be or whether
if they took over south korea you know
mass murder wouldn't take place and that
kind of thing but my point is is that
the ideology
doesn't necessarily dictate
genocide in other words it's an ideology
i think that that makes
genocide sometimes too easily possible
given
you know the way it thinks through
history as being you know you're on the
right side of history and some people
are on the wrong side of history and you
have to destroy those people who are on
the wrong side of history i mean there
is something in
you know marxism leninism which which
you know has that kind of language and
that kind of thinking
but i don't think um it's um
necessarily that way there's a wonderful
historian at uh berkeley named martin
malia
who uh has written uh you know wrote a
number of books on this subject and he
was very very
uh he was very he was convinced that the
um
you know that the ideology itself
uh you know played a crucial role in the
murderousness of the soviet regime i'm
not completely convinced you know when i
say not completely convinced i think
there or you could argue it different
ways
equally valid
you know with equally valid arguments
i mean
there's something about
the ideology of of communism
that allows you to decrease the value of
human life
almost like this philosophy if it's okay
to crack a few eggs to make an omelet
right so maybe that if you can reason
like that
then it's easier to take the leap
of for the good of the country for the
good of the people for the good of the
world it's okay to kill a few people
and then that's where
i
i
i wonder about the slippery slope yeah
no no again you know i don't think it's
a slippery slope i think it's um
i think it's dangerous in other words i
think it's dangerous but i don't i don't
consider
you know i don't like marxism feminism
any better than the next guy and i've
lived in plenty of those systems to know
how they can beat people down and how
they can
you know
destroy human aspirations and and human
interaction between people but
they're not necessarily murderous
systems
they are systems that contain people's
autonomy that
force people to into work and labor and
lifestyles that they don't want to live
i spent a lot of time you know with with
the east germans and poles
uh you know who lived in and even
and even in the soviet union
um you know when the post stalin period
where people lived lives they didn't
want to live you know and and hadn't
didn't have the freedom to choose
uh and that was terrifying in and of
itself but these were not murderous
systems
and they and they they and and they you
know ascribe to marxism violence so i
suppose it's important to draw the line
between mass murder
and
genocide and mass murder
versus
just
mass violation of human rights right
right
and the leap to mass murder
you're saying um
may be easier in some ideologies than
others but it's not clear that somehow
one ideology definitely leads to mass
murder not exactly
you